[Music]
we do now in Erasmus so in Europe where
would you go
I would get to one of the East European
countries because when I grew up the
world was still in Berlin the Cold War
was still on I went to Bulgaria on
Erasmus seven years ago
okay how did you like it the beginning
of my life like the real start of my
adult life freedom finding myself
discovering my possibilities my own
talents my flaws of course as well and
when you come back you miss that
independence now for me it gives me the
idea to make others experience like this
one
[Music]
I have the feeling that the European
Union is getting less and less popular
do you think the Erasmus program could
reverse the trend for me democracy is
all about people that you realize that
yes I have my own things but we also
have problems that we can only solve in
common and then when you meet in a way
where you really get to know people I
think you get a strong idea that you can
solve things together
I think it's a small miracle every day
you agree with someone with another
mother tones another political
background another cultural background
another history and yet I experience on
a daily basis that that it's doable
because we care about having job for
young people climate change and that
seems bigger than the differences among
them with the European Commission that
financed some project like the EU's
exchange I've done it's really great
because people that doesn't have any
money can take part as well and that is
what is very nice with this exchange
because you become more global more
European when you get to know a culture
and so on you discover another part of
yourself you adapt and when you come
back you're with a mix between your
native culture and the one you got to
know better I never wish to have to be
young again but this is actually a
little telling I'm sorry
you